cinq candidats en tout aux
clayes-sous-bois il ya également
stéphanie jamin bonsoir on ça vous êtes
la tête de liste d'énergie positive une
démarche citoyenne et sans étiquette
vous êtes que les siennes depuis plus de
30 ans dans la vie vous êtes est
responsable responsable administrative
et financière impliqué dans le milieu
associatif local pourquoi vous lancer
cette fois ci dans une démarche
politique
alors du coup on se lance avec une
équipe dans cette démarche de des
municipales pour pour le mois de mars
prochain puisque on a senti depuis
quelque temps que les claies avait
besoin d'un nouveau dynamisme d'un
rajeunissement de l'équipe municipale
donc on nous avons souhaité proposer une
liste citoyenne soutenue par aucun parti
politique pour proposer un regard
nouveau
oak les siens donc citoyenne ça veut
dire que ces composés de personnes qui
ne sont pas engagés dans le conseil
municipal des clayes-sous-bois
effectivement donc on est aussi parti du
constat que les trois listes
enfin la quatrième liste n'était pas
encore sorti mais que les trois listes
en présence permettait de reconstituer
la totalité hormis de personnes me
semble du conseil municipal actuel donc
donc on a voulu proposer quelque chose
de différent il y avait aussi cette
interrogation sur sur madame frémont et
monsieur guy guen qui vont tous voter
pendant 14 ans ensemble et qui
maintenant se sont se sont ne
s'entendait plus donc en fait on saisit
que les chrétiens méritait mieux qu'une
guerre une guerre et une liste citoyenne
était importante pour les municipales le
président lui semble parler de deux
listes qui sont également engagés qui
sont conduites par deux actuel adjoint
de la commune des clayes-sous-bois les
clayes sous bois où la maire sortante
véronique côté millard ne se
représentera pas elle est élue depuis
2001 à la tête de la commune quel regard
vous portez sur l'action portée par
véronique côté millard à la tête des
clayes-sous-bois alors effectivement je
trouve que son bilan il ya des très
belles choses qui ont pu être faites
enfin il faut tout n'est pas négatif aux
clayes-sous-bois sinon je ne serais pas
resté enfin parce que je suis revenue
quand j'ai voulu fonder ma famille donc
clairement je ne serais pas resté si
tous ne me plaisait pas mais moi en
terme de bilan on est assez mitigé on a
un peu du mal à comprendre quel est le
bilan de madame véronique côté millard
hormis le manque de transparence sur la
communication sur les différents projets
également sur l'engagement de la
dernière campagne pour revenir sur nos
centres de loisirs des bruyères campagne
avait été fait on met deux jusqu'en mai
2014 où on nous avait parlé de ce centre
de loisirs des bruyères qui devait être
rénové et puis finalement on apprend
mais 2015 que tout est arrêté on nous
annonce aussi qu on a besoin d'eux
de ce budget pour rénover les écoles
donc moi ça me pose la question de la
promesse qui a été faite et de l'absence
de la respecter et aussi sur la gestion
puisque en un an on nous annonce que
toutes les écoles doivent être faites
donc comment a pu ne pas attendre ne pas
anticiper à ce point la réfection de
toutes les écoles
donc je suis assez mitigé sur le débat
de madame côté mia est vraiment un
manque de communication de transparence
et un problème aussi sur tout ce qui est
programme immobilier qui a marqué
beaucoup ces dernières années alors
votre campagne stephenie jamais un
tourne autour de valeurs d'écologie de
solidarité justement l'écologique est
l'un des axes prioritaires de de votre
programme vous souhaitez porter un réel
développement durable aux
clayes-sous-bois quelles sont les
propositions que vous avez en la matière
alors effectivement oui alors le
développement durable et c'est quelque
chose qui est très important puisque on
est quand même dans un climat d'urgence
climatique et environnementale donc on a
envie de proposer des vraies mesures
notamment sur la végétalisation des
espaces qui permettent de d1p
remobiliser les sols et ça c'est très
important surtout quand on sait que ces
dernières années il ya beaucoup de
choses qui ont été beaucoup d'arbres qui
ont été supprimés beaucoup d espace qui
ont été bétonnée donc on veut travailler
là dessus on veut également travailler
sur les audits énergétiques de tous les
deux sous les bâtiments publics puisque
parce qu'il ya pas mal de
d'investissement qui ont été faits sur
ces dernières années mais est ce qu'il
n'ya pas de la déperdition d'énergie
donc ça est également tout ce qui est
sur les mobilités douces les pistes
cyclables oakley on les compte elles ne
sont pas entretenues et puis encore une
fois il ya des investissements qui sont
faits sur des présents sur la rue jean
jaurès non pas la nuit jean jaurès mais
sur la bulle ferrer pardon et pas de
piste cyclable de prévu donc la mobilité
douce est vraiment un sujet oakley
surtout que c'est une ville qui est de
plus en plus engorgées avec tous les
centres commerciaux aux alentours donc
la mobilité douce est quelque chose de
très importantes alors autres sujets que
vous souhaitez porter ses plus de
transparence une démocratie locale plus
transparents tenir par exemple neuf
conseils municipaux parents et instaurer
un temps d'échangé entre les clés siens
et les élus au début de séance pourquoi
vouloir aller dans ce sens alors je
pense qu'il est important de redonner
confiance aux questions parce que depuis
quelques années comme je vous disais ya
vraiment un manque de transparence et de
communication
mais qu'est ce qui les classe ayant
besoin d'une équipe municipale qui
soient à leur écoute qui puisse répondre
à leurs questions qu'ils soient
présentes à leurs côtés et c'est surtout
qu'on les écoute
donc c'est pour ça qu'on est une liste
citoyenne est attentif à ce qu'on veut
faire attention à nos à nos concitoyens
donc ont vraiment travaillé là dessus il
ya toute cette partie conseil municipal
mais il ya aussi sûr
travailler avec la minorité minorité
municipale alors confiant la présidence
d'une commission d'appel d'offres donc
on veut travailler sur ce sujet et notre
rôle aussi ces deux pour bien vivre
ensemble ces deux de ré expliquer aux
gens ce qu'ils pensent que les élus
doivent faire comme mon travail
et quels sont les points les
prérogatives de chacun donc lors de la
pédagogie autour des missions d'un
conseil municipal tout à fait pour que
chacun comprenne ce qu'on peut faire ce
qu'on peut pas faire pourquoi es tu
vraiment cette souci de transparence et
de pédagogie qui permettra un mieux
vivre ensemble et un meilleur respect de
chacun et c'est seulement échanger ou
c'est aussi leur donner peut-être la
part à certaines décisions voilà la
démocratie participative être l'un des
thèmes aussi de cette campagne des
municipales
comment vous voyez les choses alors
effectivement on a envie d'ouvrir les
commissions à des clés siens qui les
modalités sont encore à définir mon
envie de leur ouvrir des commissions
notamment les commissions des affaires
scolaires où on pourrait peut-être
intégrer les parents d'élèves de manière
plus systématique également les
animateurs des centres de loisirs qui
ont leur mot à dire sur les projets et
puis toutes les personnes qui ont envie
de participer peuvent venir aux
commissions il ya ce côté là est
également un budget participatif avec
des projets pour l'intérêt général où
les clients pourront décider ce sera
votée encore après mai
de participer au développement de leur
ville un mot aussi votre regard pour
terminer nous reste 30 secondes sur
l'intégration des clayes-sous-bois dans
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines elle en fait partie
depuis 2016 et on rappelle que pour ces
élections municipales on élit aussi les
conseillers communautaires
quel regard vous portez sur cette
intégration de la commune gic 30
secondes mais du coup ce que je voulais
vous dire c'est que j'ai effectivement
il faut qu'on tienne nos engagements et
prenne nos responsabilités par rapport à
saint quentin en yvelines
il va falloir que on arrête de dire que
cette fois la faute de 50 ans quand il
ya le moindre souci au niveau de la
voirie des éclairages il faut que
quelqu'un en mairie qui sont capables de
relayer les demandes de suivre des
dossiers
donc ça je pense que c'est très
important et c'est ce sur quoi on veut
s'engager pour les prochaines années
vos prochains rendez vous de campagne
avec attention nous tenons des réunions
publiques le 29 février à andré proulx
de 10h à 12h le dimanche 8 mars jour de
la femme de 16 heures à 18 heures aux
commandes du château et ensuite à rené
coty le 12 mars de 20h30 à 22h30
merci stéphanie jamin tête de liste
d'énergie positive aux clayes-sous-bois
face à vous je le rappelle l'adjointe au
maire à l'éducation anne-claire frémont
le premier adjoint actuel philippe
guiguen et l'élu d'opposition nicolas
hué donc on en parle est un cette
cinquième candidature celle d'olivier
augustin pour lutte ouvrière